[Music]
absolutely
[Music]
oh what a lad and what a lad i have for
you all today today's guest he first
burst onto the scene as a superstar with
the new zealand seven side before
becoming a legend in the 15-man game
with the wellington lions and of course
the hurricanes he is also a double a
double rugby world cup winner with the
all blacks in 2011 and 2015 and since
moving to la rochelle in france he has
chalked over 100 games for them at a
world-class level
and as you're all about to find out he
is one of the biggest lads you will ever
meet it is the great victor vito welcome
brother
hey rory man what an intro you do it so
well for every single person i've heard
on this place so it's awesome bro
matt you're an easy one to pump up
you've done so many cool things
oh crunchy carry on bro
[Laughter]
but anyway i need to start need to start
with something current your testicles
currently not playing because you're out
with the testicle injury
talk to me about this oh how did this
happen
oh man
my team yeah we played against leon had
a home game
defensive scrum well they put me on at
seven i was on the open side i let the
eight get around me too far which i
think is just the sign of the times
um and then as i was wrapping up his uh
waste as he made it to our first
offender the other our other defender
managed to whip his leg around and kick
me straight in the nuts so
i carried on for
until half time played another 15 or 10
minutes or something went off and i knew
something was up but far out i knew that
yeah something was up but it wasn't
until i looked down after the game and
had like the size of an orange i don't
normally have that's the size of an
orange freaking with the left knight
anyway far off that was huge
i ain't beaver but um sorry it was it
was crazy so sore so sensitive like
sensitive it was it was
nuts well excuse a bunch but far out it
was crazy bro and so i'm out for two or
three weeks and they're still sensitive
today
true so what what's the rehab for that
oh honestly they did a scan and they
were like oh it looks like it's
fractured and i was like a friction not
what is it and you're like oh operation
when they're going to need to
sold together or take it out i was like
oh man i was freaking i was freaking
hell out man i was like what the hell
does that mean can i still have kids or
yeah all the frenches are like oh at
least you got three already and i was
like [ __ ] yeah well still whatever
working nut though but um luckily they
just went to a specialist the next
morning and he said look it should be
all right if you just if it starts going
down then we can just leave it like that
and it will just take two or three weeks
to start running but no exertion or
activity like that so just chill for two
weeks and then we'll see how you feel so
the last week in a bit i've just been
literally sitting on my ass doing
nothing
crazy
and was that pain you know when you get
a little tap in the nuts and it's just
excruciating pain was it like that but
times 100 or is there sort of a yeah
i just felt like going for a [ __ ] the
whole time like once it happened i just
had this little knot in my stomach and i
just felt like i needed to go for a [ __ ]
and they lasted for about
three four days they're feeling like but
i couldn't pushed the id though because
i just it would just felt like i was
gonna explode or something just behind
my head so oh it was it's wrong but uh
i'm surprised it doesn't have heaven
more often to be fair but
there we go i just i guess i deserve to
kick in the nuts for letting that number
eight get so far outside me
and when you come back is how you how do
you think it's going to be when you come
back everything's just back to normal
just you don't have to wear any sort of
pad or box cricket box or anything
uh
man yeah don't
think so i think they're just gonna wait
till they say they're just gonna it's
just gonna work in terms of how much
pain i got so it's amazing the amount of
times
you actually graze your nuts on random
things like you know your pen league or
you're sitting down in a chair and you
just take it for granted you don't even
think about it but when they're this saw
literally like every little movement is
so to think about running around a rugby
field right now like man i've got
another week at least i can so it's just
gonna wait for it to go down with the
pain and then i can i can come back
that's crazy and how are the boys going
at the moment um over there in the comp
what's the what's the competition like
with covert i see a few games get
cancelled but it seems to be getting
most of them uh getting through most of
them
yeah they're getting through most of
them a couple of games or a few games
last week got cancelled
we're coming in at fifth at the moment
had a good home win that time against
leon
had a game cancelled then we played just
recently went away and we freaking lost
that game to cast
so we're sitting in our fifth at the
moment but the table is literally
six points you know separating the top
guys and the sixth guy so it's it's not
much not much between us at the moment
and is covert running rampant over there
at the moment again or is that all
pretty under control now
uh it was under control when they um
like when we got our vaccine like
vaccines um they just said look we're
not once everyone gets their doses we're
not going to test anymore and we'll just
keep playing our games but um since they
announced the mandates for the third
they started testing again and yeah look
most teams like it's rugby like we're
literally tackling and touching each
other all the damn time and cases are
starting to mount up and
yeah games are getting cancelled now and
starting to look a bit ominous for the
future like we've already had bath our
game uh
transferred to another date so postponed
sorry
so we're gonna have to play that maybe
in the holiday period in february coming
up so
yeah it's it's all over the place at the
moment because as soon as you have five
cases your game has to get cancelled and
you know sometimes you're having like 15
cases each week so
crazy and you're a covered survivor too
aren't you
how did you find it
mate it was actually um it was actually
um weird it was just like a bad flu
where i just got a bit of a fever for a
day or two
and then um if anything the worst thing
about it was i lost my uh taste i lost
my taste i couldn't really smell too
much
um and so you know food and that was uh
pretty not enjoyable but it was kind of
good i guess because i also was just
able to eat some good stuff and it
tasted just as good at the bed as the
bad stuff so i
started being a little bit better with
my diet that way so no it was good man
i managed to get through a while and
amber was okay and it's just i'm
actually kind of glad that we had it now
because that fear is kind of gone like
for the longest time we were kind of
just like man i don't want to get it so
bad and yes it's it's pretty niggly but
um luckily we're young enough in our
case to
to get it not so bad move on and
yeah and just carry on but some guys
have got it twice already three times
some guys in our team so
it's gonna be around for a while yeah
and how long did you lose your smell and
taste for was it a long period it's
about six weeks bro so
about five or six weeks um pretty long
time
pretty long time for a guy that likes
his tapas so um man it was it was a long
six weeks but thank god they're back now
thank god and other than um covert and a
swollen testicle you've managed to have
a pretty good run over there like you've
wrapped up a heap of games eh so i
remember the first few years you're over
there i don't think you missed a game
for like the first three seasons and
they play
heaps of games obviously so you're well
over 100 games already over there so
have you found the footy
mate the 40 year like you say um barely
missed the game in my first few seasons
and i think that's why i'm a bit of a
broken arse now
literally just paying for it now um
yeah i played nearly 100 games in my
first three and a half four seasons so
yeah it's literally um they wreck them
up pretty quick over here and what's
quite interesting is you know the the
seasonal change but the atmosphere
doesn't change if you know what i mean
in terms of the team and obviously back
home we've got super and the united
states when you go to a different team a
bit of a change in scenery changing guys
um but here it's you know the same team
pretty much you know for pre-season
through to mid-season and off season for
10 months sort of thing so
it's
yeah it's it's a long grind but um
that's where it is a
bit of a marathon as opposed to a race
like it is back home and the rugby
itself man it's gone so much better like
when i first got here it was
the defense was playing up like guys
rushing in and out of lines creating
holes everywhere it's probably why i
wasn't so bad in the first year whereas
now um as everyone has seen with french
rugby it's it's pretty damn good uh so
it's much tougher
and we've spoken to jason eaton about
lara show a little bit and the one thing
that stood out to me was how you guys
were training and just training games
you weren't doing skills or anything
like that no patterns no game plan it
was just playing games is it still like
that or
give us a little bit of run down on that
there's
still elements there's still elements of
that we do love to play a little bit of
drop off touch and all that kind of
stuff still but um
a lot more a lot more change i guess
once uh
guys like we've had johnny gibbs come
through now and ronan agara obviously
they've got a few more ideas as to what
they want to be playing like and some
set pieces and whatnot so there's a lot
more of their focus now um it wasn't to
say even when piggy was here we
obviously focused on our set piece
because like honestly set piece wins
everything yeah if you've got a scrum
if you've got a line out more like or
you can go to win your lineup or first
but if you've got those three things
sussed
you're pretty much gonna be guaranteed
to be in the top eight you know every
year so
they spend a lot of time on that and
then uh when they actually you know play
phase rape you made it's just
we call it dissort over here so it's
just like it's a disorder this lights
disorderly the games they just kick the
ball we play
choose another ball kick it somewhere
else and just keep playing it's uh
it's full on especially for these old
knees but uh
it's uh it's the way the game's going
whether some of the sequences going on
pretty long
yeah and how are your knees like you've
spoken about your body being a little
bit broken is that mainly just your
knees
oh it's just my right knee bro um yeah
i've got grade four arthritis on there
so it's just um just been a bit of a
matter of time
just a matter of time and if anything
had a little surgery
uh late last year around september and
just to get the meniscus right and
that's worked that's worked quite well
um it's just the pain now you know it
doesn't blow up anymore but i've just
got to manage the pain so
if anything it's just my um my pain
through shoulder how long that can hold
out for and i'm a bit of a wimp so i
don't know how much longer i've got
do you feel that when you're out playing
or is it more during the week training
man it's actually yeah 100 during the
week i would say um
during the week it's you know it's just
all the the ford sessions and the you
know all our team runs and all that i
think that
getting through those are way harder
than getting yourself up for one
80-minute game on a saturday yeah you
know you can take a few pills and strap
it up and run around like hey man but as
soon as that strapping comes off bro
like my legs like a noodle so
it's uh definitely the training that's
uh that makes it tougher
now get that get because that gets
really hard dna and then you start
you're not you're probably not able to
do extras or you're pretty quick to get
off the chain training field just
because your knee you want to do the
right recovery because you know a good
knee is probably better than what you're
going to get it get out staying out on
the field trying to do a few more extras
is it like that as well
yeah 100 during the week bro like i
started like i never used to be someone
that likes swapping in and out like i
just love getting reps and just
perfecting my timing with my
relationships with the you know the tens
or whoever whoever i'm working with
never lost never liked swapping out but
now like it's swapping out my best
friend like just to save the knees and
do a little bit more mental homework at
home on huddle or whatever so
it's uh it's definitely changed but i
mean that's hey that's uh that's just
what's going to happen i guess
it sounds all too familiar to me
and then it gets hard to hard to know
when when the right time for you to stop
hey because you is this the end of your
contract this season
yeah this season's the end of my
contract bro
and then you you're obviously probably
going to get big offers all around the
world a superstar like yourself
to keep playing and then it's whether
you want to take up that money or
whether you're looking to
say that enough is enough and it's a
really hard decision to make okay
yeah it is a hard decision to make
because um
yeah it's the only life you've known for
well i guess for myself professional 17
18 years it'll be going on so
it's a it's a lot of life dedicated to
one thing but at the same time
i'm quite excited to to find out what's
on the other side too you know i'm
rugby was always gonna gonna end someday
and it's probably one thing where i've
been quite lucky is um
well my school was never good at rugby
you know and they always reminded me
when i was younger like okay well what
if you break your leg and you can't have
a career what are you gonna do then so
they've always put their little water
for me and and luckily
you know i should be all right to finish
up but obviously man the money won't be
the same but um you know i should have a
little bit of a buffer to be
be able to look at other things but
rugby wise i still feel a force for the
knee like it would be like you with your
hips like if it wasn't for the hips
everything else feels good you know like
i
if my body i still feel like i can run
around it's just
yeah it's just the knee that's holding
me up a little bit so it's a hard one
when your ego is telling you you can
still go mate keep going
yeah and especially with the new carrot
probably for you at the end of the
tunnel with
the samoa eligibility rules a rugby
world cup just around the corner
have you looked much into that
oh man like it's um first of all i was
just i was just really happy to hear
that they made the change like it's
going to give so many guys opportunity
to
you know to
get back onto the international circuit
and just really showcase the best the
world really has to offer you know
especially for the you know the tongs of
samoans you know i think um
you know guys like stephen law tour and
charles pierce like all these guys are
going to be able to be seen again but
for me personally like
made up
yeah there comes that ego again man i'm
like yeah man i've got heaps of but you
know i'm thinking now 2022 we've just
entered into
world cup's a good 18 months away and
i'll have to be really
looking after my knee but also playing
some really good rugby and not taking
the opportunity away from someone else
you know like like you said before i've
won a couple of world cups now luckily
all time to while to be in those teams
and you know if someone else will really
deserve the chance to experience that
and create his own career off that i
think um
that's more what should happen then you
know unless they really needed why and i
was playing good enough you know 100
i'll never say no but
um
yeah it's just something that i'd have
to appreciate that's across at the time
but at the moment it seems pretty far
away to be fair
oh you're a lad giving up an opportunity
like that but how do you think how do
you think samoa would go like um
obviously last last world cup they'll
probably be pretty disappointed with how
they went a whole new chance to bring
back like you say a lot of experience a
lot of guys who have played it at the
highest level before how do you think
it's what sort of impact is that going
to have on the side
well i think um
i think they they still are very uh
obviously very traditional they love to
stick to the boys from the island but
there will be some experienced guys that
i'm sure they'll be looking to bring
back and obviously goody you know your
good mates obviously going to be looking
after the team so ladies they've got
some good coaches in there and i know
they've got the skills and some of the
experience uh can come back from you
know from guys like stephen as i was
saying before so
maybe there's you know guys like chris
voorhees as well he's played some top
level rugby as well so it's
it's going to be exciting to see the
kind of things that they can do and
bring together there's obviously the bus
as well you know i would love to see him
running out there
but um mate there's uh i guess they've
just got to get there they've got to
choose their squad and who they're going
to build it around and then from there
that's when they can see where they can
go i guess
any predictions what
what's the highest position uh um island
nation's going to finish at the world
cup
an island nation
okay uh well i reckon
for me um
one team i do love watching from the
islands i always have it's fiji at the
moment like
they've just they're just physical
freaks man every single player from one
to
35
like
literally
absolute specimens and
if they get their uh if they get their
set pieces and all that kind of stuff
right um i could see them quite easily
being
in a quarter if not at least if not a
semi you know like they're just that
good you know um
so i'll put my money on fiji going
pretty far
nice like that hear it here first vg
semi finals
we'll look back at this
18 months
let's go
well you did mention a little bit about
scott's college before so we will go
back to your um childhood i know you
grew up in wellington i know for a bit
about your childhood but give us a bit
of a rundown for our listeners about
what your life was like growing up
yeah um yeah born in wellington um went
to school at scott's college actually
before that i was at a little primary
school in uh
in brooklyn a public school and then my
mum actually
won a
bit of a lottery actually to get me into
a private school was like a government
uh scholarship thing just put my name in
a ballot and got pulled out so i was
pretty lucky there went to scots
and i went there from about eight years
old all the way till end of high school
played all my rugby through there and
yeah it's
literally
all my life in wellington
and uh we went there great at rugby as i
as i alluded to before so we managed to
get around and play a lot of school
student 15s and even nelson college is
second fifteen
like we literally couldn't touch your
visiting at all and i think we even lost
that second fifteen game as well as my
first theme player so
it's uh not so many great memories but
it was a good time it was a good good
learning curve and uh we definitely were
not bad by the time i left but they've
actually gone on and once as i left so
that's a couple of times actually so
that's cool they've done pretty well now
how did that lottery work like so you
weren't selected because of your
athletic ability or anything like that
was it genuinely just
lucky that
oh it was literally just
a scholarship for low-income families
that wanted to give one of their kids a
chance to go to a private school and i
think it was national government at the
time they put in two
literally in wellington it was like two
kids can go one boy one girl
there must have been i think it was 80
or close to 100 entries and
literally i just my name got pulled out
and i did an interview and school said
yes so
so lucky you know like pretty pretty
grateful to have had that opportunity
and getting to rub shoulders with some
people who um managed to
turn me on a little bit scholastically
because i was pretty horrible to do my
homework um but uh they managed to fix
that up pretty quick i went and bought
it there as well which is pretty awesome
like highly recommend that for any lads
going around like it's your boarding's
awesome experience
yeah make some good words there too
you're obviously a very well educated
man
well i i learned how to do my homework
anyway and when you're in the boarding
house we're like third form well that's
what year nine i guess they say now you
had to do two hours solid homework and
you never get that much homework you
know you get like 20 30 minutes but you
had to sit there for a solid two hours
so
like if you were caught asleep the dean
would come and literally smack you on
the back of your head so you had to do
something so or you just pretend to read
when you see the prefect coming around
but man it was it was hard yakka but i
thought some good stuff
yeah is it true you're playing soccer up
until you went to scots
yeah i played football all the way
through um i actually really loved
playing football
it wasn't it wasn't until i went to
scots that i've yeah exactly played
right because they were like i was
telling them how much i love football
and i'd love to join their first 11 or
just even try
and they were like oh yeah that's great
you look like you could play rugby and
um i looked at my mom and mum was like
yes he plays rugby like
and she hated me he hated the thought of
me playing rugby she was the whole
reason i played soccer so
yeah just like that to get the
scholarship when playing rugby and i
obviously i'm going to have to thank
them for that because um it worked out
not so bad in there
were you any good at soccer
i honestly in my mind's eye from
thinking back i felt like i was real
good but now when i look at some real
big kids running
and some little kids making way for them
i'm actually
i think i was just bigger and none of
the kids wanted me to fall on top of
them so they just made way i thought i
was good but
i got chucked in the goal a few times
too so that should be an indication
[Laughter]
so were you always a massive kid
oh yeah i was
i was a bit tubbier when i was younger
so
um always the the guy because i was an
only child you know so
i just was given all the food all the
time finished mom and dad's plate off as
well
go to the cousins and they'll have some
extra food for me as well so
unfortunately i'm put put it on a little
bit but luckily my cousins you know they
were pretty sporty and i just sort of
caught the bug off them because i was
the most uncle wine out of the lot uh
just the younger one as well so i just
chased them around trying to
play basketball or not kept on getting
thrown out of the game because i didn't
know what a double dribble was or travel
and all this other stuff but
managed to learn it and no it's yeah
luckily um they gave me a bit of that
upbringing to play some sport
and what was it like going to scott's
college i i'd imagine you were one of a
few islanders i wouldn't imagine was
there was there many islanders there
yeah there's a grand total of about four
of us
boy in the whole yeah
yeah one whole college in the whole
college so all the way because scott
said uh they started primaries from five
years old all the way up to 17 and i
think there were literally only four of
us
there was a young guy tim satu took me
under his wing and he looked after me
and yeah it was tough man like because
we obviously low-income scholarship and
then all of a sudden i'm
in this posture as uniform kids are
rolling up and mercedes and all these
nice ass cars and
the drop offs and
gaps and the ties mate it was um was
pretty daunting at first to be fair and
they did this thing called cross country
which i felt was absolutely unnecessary
there's all the running like all these
house meets little house sports and it
was awesome but that was the one that
and swimming that i just never looked
forward to and um made it was
definitely out of my comfort zone but um
i think any growth comes from any
challenge and i definitely had to had to
grow pretty quick over there
um yeah like you say about all the rich
kids did you did you feel uncomfortable
around that or did you just own it own
it being from the low income family
i was only like eight years old so to be
fair i was actually quite embarrassed
like that i didn't have i didn't have
some of the things like i wouldn't um
i wouldn't even go to parties sometimes
because you know like kids are having
parties all the time they're like oh i'm
turning nine you've got to come and
i'll go to a the first period the
birthday i went to was in one of my
mates nigel they went to like mcdonald's
or something the classic park there we
went there took presents and
my prison must have only cost about 10
bucks not even which is a lot for us
and like he's getting like action
minions and all these meanest toys and
i'm just like oh don't open my present
like i think i gave him a boomerang like
like a phone i gave him a phone
boomerang like and he was like so good
though he was like oh no thanks man this
is awesome i could just see it and i was
like i'm not going any more of these
birthdays so
okay
yeah funnily enough the kids were good
enough to still invite me even though
they saw my presents um but i started
like showing away from those sorts of
things where i had to sort of um
show my wealth or my lack of i guess um
and then like when i got dropped off
home like we had a tiny little rack
shack house and
and i just tell them to drop me off
around the corner you know like nah i
just remember at the dairy like it's all
good like my mom i've got to grab
something for my mom
full of like straight out lie
i'll just be like later later they drop
me i did i just walk around some of my
households because i don't want them
seeing where i was so
yeah it was it wasn't easy but um
yeah
yeah it was uh it was an interesting
experience i've learned a lot from it
though
mate that's crazy so the when did the
when did the rugby start for you
obviously once you went there did you
pick it up straight away were you
naturally gifted
um
i think um
yeah now the first time they put me into
the rugby team obviously it would have
only just been eight or nine and um
we played a rugby game they gave me the
ball
i saw a whole line of kids running at me
i actually ran backwards and i just
freaking threw the ball over my head
and so
they were like uh not gone like
it's uh yeah it was it's quite funny
i'll never forget it like and then my
coach pulled me aside and he was like
man i know you're scared i need to play
soccer i'm and like i was scared i was
like what the hell is going on here i've
been playing soccer my whole life and
these guys want to take my head off
and so um but then the first time like
the next the next week then i ran
forward i actually scored a try so and i
was like oh like it hurt getting hit and
all that but odds you've sort of slowly
learned it's not such a big game and all
of a sudden yeah just i don't know i was
a bit bigger as well so
yeah i just managed to make some rep
teams and got taken through by some
really good players under their wings as
well and
yeah just went through the whites and
age grades i guess and yeah it was lucky
enough to go through with guys like fifa
and
and serge lilo and guys all that so yeah
it's been been a pretty cool ride coming
through weinstein
and when did you think that rugby could
actually be a career when did you think
this was this could be a thing here
uh it was probably wasn't until i made
new zealand 17s
oh yeah and i went to their camp in
palmerston north and they obviously
they've got like a camp up there for a
week and
you know when once i started seeing some
of the names that i've i'd only really
read in papers because like our team was
no good but i'd heard of you know there
were guys like tama makamaka and like
elliot all these
all these well-known names back in the
day um when i saw them in the same camp
as me and i everyone was already talking
about them being all blacks one day i
was like
man like if i'm rubbing a shoulder then
maybe maybe i can make something out of
this and it wasn't until their camp
really um but that dream got broken
pretty quick went out to do the 3k
they did the 3k time trial and then you
know like coming back behind some of the
props and they're like mate are you a
loose sport or what like
like pretty pretty good speed time
pretty good this and that and then all
of a sudden the 3k and i was just like
man you're horrible so
oh it's um steep learning curve at each
step but uh yeah never really been a
long distance
you must have gone back and worked on
that uh worked on your fitness pretty
hard because then you did end up making
the new zealand 19s i think you're
captain of new zealand 21s or
something like that so
um was that that was fitness pretty much
the only thing you needed to work on
yeah that was probably my achilles heel
for a long time and um if anything i was
just lucky uh when i was 16
to um have gone along to a wellington
sevens uh
training uh those over the summer there
was no not much rugby going on so
i just decided to go have a run with
them and they played a couple of uh
tonys as they do as they go around
nothing official just yet
and i managed to
get a bit more fitness um work off a bit
of the puppy fit and you know went down
to queenstown when i was 17.
and it was made i had a ball um i
actually went to the new zealand sevens
camp and that that broke me um
fitness-wise like i knew as soon as i
made it through there camp i was like if
i can make it through this then you know
like one thing that looks like a bullo
he used to say is like you're not gonna
die we're always on the line and i felt
like i was gonna die but he always
reminded us remember boys you're not
gonna die and so um yeah yeah i think
going through touches camp really uh
literally reshaped me uh as a player
just because i wasn't so
wasn't so worried about it ready to push
the limits i guess
may and then was that was that before so
you didn't make the squad that time but
a few years later
um you were in the squad and absolutely
ripping it up i remember everyone
remembers the wellington sevens
tournament where you
sort of burst onto the scene didn't you
but pre that tournament no one really
knew who victor vito was after it
everyone knew who you were so what was
what was that whole experience like
made um you know i think anyone that
goes through the the seventh circle will
touch um can appreciate how hard you
work um obviously you know um it's
it's hard yakka but man it's so much fun
like you know you're playing music in
the changing room before you go out like
it's it's a pretty pure form of rugby
you know like
it's defensively like there's no one to
clean up your mistakes you know you make
one mistake well that's a try like it's
gone um so i love my time there and um
if anything
just helped me sort of learn how to how
to work with space and sort of trust
myself as well to to just go for it i
think that's one thing that titch always
taught me um i was always a little bit
hesitant when i was a rugby player
because
um because i came through a school there
wasn't that well known like i never
really felt like i deserved to be in
these
bigger teams like these rep teams
because it was you know wellington
colleges st patstown you know uh silver
stream all these
guys that come through that never even
heard of me because i'm playing freaking
div three div two rugby you know
um so i always had that little thing
where i was like oh i'll just offload or
make it for someone else but sevens was
like the first time it was like
literally you go and score the trial
like you got to go do it so i think that
experience was awesome for me not only
for fitness but also just being able to
back myself and go
and you're on the wing there 2a so
was that was that part of that
yeah so
yeah i don't know what happened but
somewhere along the line i i picked up a
little bit of pace because i was never
like that quick but
i think just training with the sevens
boys and i think a lot of the time too
actually i'll be on the
the outside side of the scrum so i would
scrum because i was a loose forward and
closer to the sideline and then as soon
as it went out i would just reload like
they were trying they knew i wasn't the
footer so they'll just
keep me staying just doing as little
work as possible and poor dj and that
are running hard out like i hope they're
doing all the work so they looked after
me pretty well so
um yeah the wing was awesome bro it was
a good good place to learn is the game
and also knowing how to how to reach
space and trying to beat guys one-on-one
um and what was it like post that
tournament because obviously you did
have an amazing tournament that year and
um you did people were comparing you to
jonah and all these massive claims so
what was it like for you to sort as a
young fella to
handle all that
made um jonah was one of the big guys i
always looked up to so i knew as soon as
they started talking like that um
you know i always got reminded of you
know you're never as good as they say
you're never as bad as they say so i
think um yeah yeah i think i just knew
that uh it was it was a bit of a bubble
to make sure to keep my feet on the
ground and luckily i had good people
around me and always had that thing
around about me that i yeah just just
try and
just keep it level because i knew i
hadn't done anything yet because all you
know 15s is where i knew i wanted to go
but um i just wanted to enjoy the moment
of
being who i am and they could never be
another jonah and i think he told me
that actually i ran into ran into him at
a supermarket one time
and he just that it just happened um
funnily enough and he was just like
first thing he said to me he was like
bro just you know you're you bro you be
you don't worry about anything else and
i was just like yeah thank god because i
could never be there because he's huge
but like
he is
absolute monster you know like so
awesome to hear it from the horse's
mouth so yeah i just needed to be me and
i'm i'm glad the advice is given to me
by the man himself
how good is that advice from jonah i
love it in the supermarket
miramar let's go
did you ever think about playing wing
though like in the 15-man game because i
remember there being sort of whispers
that you might look at playing wing or
um
might be more suited to wing on at 15
said did they ever cross your mind
yeah
it's funny i um i had this conversation
with with smithy wayne smith and um
this is once i made the all blacks as
loose forward obviously and i think a
couple years in he was like did you know
that i actually wanted to transform you
into a winger when i first saw you but
um we always had me playing i was on the
bench a lot obviously for the all blacks
but i'd always be covering wing you know
some for some reason you'd pull me out
and you'd be like oh vic during this
training week i needed to start
practicing your up and unders and i was
like
oh all right sweet i'm not holding back
at eight so it was a swing he was like
yeah yeah just the just what if like it
won't happen and then sure enough like
against canada and the world cup they're
like
i started at the
loose ford at seven and then i finished
up their wing so
it's uh yeah i i never seriously
gathered any thought though because i
always
i always knew i wanted to be a loose
forward because i found it way more i
love the the camaraderie and the
forwards and i knew i wasn't anywhere
near fast enough to be a winger so
um
yeah definitely glad i stayed in the
forwards
yeah longevity too with the knees tough
tough getting into top speed with dodgy
knees
but you'd obviously already played for
the wellington lions before that
tournament so what was that like going
from being in wellington lions is i
think you were 19 20 and then coming
back post the sevens was there was there
much of a difference there you're
obviously playing with lots of legends i
think the all blacks were still playing
in the comp those days so
and wellington had some big names in
their side
yeah so when i first met the lions in
2006 it was um pretty crazy because i'm
playing with legends like you know
thomas waldron jerry collins chris
massoy rodney soyalo like
these are all like all blacks and super
rugby stars and you know even scooter
wardrobe
like guys that are just legendary for me
and um it was probably the best um
some of the best years i've ever had
just learning under those guys and
coming through that generation
and obviously then jerry moved on and
wrote as i got to play with him in the
hurricanes and he moved on it's just
yeah just to have been able to play with
those lads
and then obviously in the lines and then
going to sevens coming back after with
jamie joe like that was probably
he's the one that actually pulled me out
of the sevens and
he told me i needed you because we had
two more tournaments left in the sevens
and he uh asked me look if you want to
play 15s you've got to come back now
and i said oh okay i'll i'll do that had
a meeting with him sat down he was like
mates uh how do you think you're you're
going in the 15's game and i was like oh
um i think i'm right he's like i think
you might need to harden up and i was
like oh
and i was like man like
alrighty i knew it though like i knew i
was accountable accountable enough to
know and i was like no i agree 100 he
goes yeah we're going to get you into
those dark places mate don't you worry
and then from there like literally some
of the trainings we did
around uh 2008 2009
made it was uh unreal like
yeah just worked so hard
worked so so hard doing so many tackles
so many more so much rocky like was he
probably was the one guy that helped me
really uh honed my craft a little bit as
a as a bit more of a loose forward being
able to get my head into those dark
places
were you ever tempted to just stay with
sevens or was it never an option for you
uh
it was tempting more for the lads
because i loved the love touring i was
certain you know i was young at the time
was like 21 or something and just
flowing around you know we had
we just left san diego and hong kong and
all that and i was we had i think we had
scotland and london left back in those
days so um you know it's pretty exciting
i was like yeah man let's go but um i
knew i always wanted to
aim for the all blacks and i knew
actually more the hurricanes or the
hurricanes you know i just really wanted
to make their team
and uh the way things worked out from
then as well was pretty unreal
yeah and then you did make the hurricane
so what what was it like going into that
team though the team of your dreams your
team you always wanted to play for
finally get in there what was what was
it like going in there
oh it was um it was unreal like just
like i said having guys at rodney around
and just learning off the wisdom that
they had like you know i had a problem
with fitness and that but he was
probably someone that never got tired
you know literally didn't even sweat
would be doing massive uh finest
sessions even thomas wardroom like for a
big guy like man he can shift and he was
fit it was um it was a really good
learning curve for for me with how they
worked and how they place themselves
even barney like love to to drop a long
punt from the 22 if he just caught it at
eight or something so it also gave me
their license to just well not that i
ever really kicked the ball but more
just to be yourself really when you when
you're in the team
and so
um i got actually injured early on um i
got left behind sorry in africa when
they left
in my first season i went and played
sevens came back i actually got caught
called over to africa because scooter
tried to rip a ripper hook shot i think
and indoor cricket and then he got
injured done his uh on his rib so i got
called over and literally played the
whole year from then on in 2009.
crazy was that at number eight
uh i started number six actually started
at number six
and obviously
massive hurricane's career ended up with
a hundred
games exactly um what a way to finish
that was but
your whole hurricane's journey was um
one of the greats and
one thing that really stands out was the
2015 final um when we lost to the
highlanders it was a year where felt
like we probably should have won it um
we were
we were pretty much unbeatable for most
of that year and then we get to the
final and
um couldn't do the job and i remember
just how upset you were after that game
i remember you
not coming out for a for a while you
were pretty um home but home ridden for
a while there a so talk to me about that
whole experience leading up to that
final and how you felt
oh look um if anything yet that final
leading up to it i think it was just
more when i was thinking of how well
we'd been doing i think we just finished
you know from the regular season uh
pasting uh i think we finished we beat
the highlanders in our last game well
they gave him a creaming in hawke's bay
and then we ended up playing a couple
games i think we finished with the
brumbies as well like beat them quite
convincingly as well
and hitting it to their final with
everything that was happening during the
week with legends like snakey and mara
and franksy and thrush all these guys
heading off i was like
if there was a time to do it man it's
it's now and um yeah just the way the
hondas came out we just made they
absolutely took us by surprise that we
were never able to recover
and like you say that game finish they
won and i couldn't even um
i was just so disappointed for the fans
and just for my family and everyone
because i because i'd expected it so bad
you know that we were going to win
literally like because of how mean we
were rolling the whole year
um and then literally i just stayed home
you're right like i think i came out and
did our mad sunday
or may monday and just after that
literally went home and didn't leave
till like
wednesday or thursday i think it was to
go down the road to get a coffee i just
i just stayed i didn't want to see
anyone because i was just so
so ashamed really i was like yeah we
were such build-ups you know like
freaking out like yeah we're gonna do it
here let's organize the party for after
let's do this and then the next minute
hello
holidays freaking celebrating obviously
oh man obviously i can look back now
after 2 16 and be happy for them but um
it's almost like they had to happen for
us to be able to win 2016 because um
man what a what a way to come back and
what a bunch of leads we had there next
year to you know to learn that lesson
from 15 and roll on
but it's interesting hearing you talk
about um
obviously people because when you go out
in wellington everyone knows you like
you get i've been out in town with you
or like been obviously i live with you
for a bit so we're going to market and
stuff you like when you're walking down
the supermarket everyone stops or
everyone everyone knows you and says
g'day to you you are a big deal in
wellington so like do you feel that
extra pressure when you when your side
does win or when the side does lose or
whether you play good or bad do you feel
like
um when you're going out there you're
being judged like that
i think um
like yeah well we you take the good with
the bandwidth right because we're so
passionate you know like our fans and
and we love playing for the fans we love
playing for our family and if anything
it's those big games and just knowing
the history of the canes too you know
we've never won one i think that was
more
you know and the fact that we're able to
bring a game home
you know and the form we had you know um
but there's something new they always
said in all blacks you know those big
games full means nothing it's really
just who's there on the day and
and that's literally what happened to us
so um you just feel disappointed for the
fact that you couldn't bring one home
for the fans and like i say i could
probably still be dark in that game if
we never won 2016 but i'm allowed to let
let the dead dogs lie so
yeah 2016 thank you very much
yeah now let's talk about 2016 we'll
roll straight into that one what a year
that was started off very slow
um but got there at the end what do you
remember about that year
oh that year 2016.
yeah i just remember getting a pasting
from the brumbies in our first game
lonnie grabbing a pig for the boys i
think the night before and then they're
getting blamed for the reason we go to
hiding but i don't know if it was that
um
and we had like oh man like crisis
meeting from way back for that game and
then
obviously went through and i think uh
when we decided to change our d
i think that was probably one of the the
master strokes of um what happened that
year um you know just us coming up a bit
more in the blitz i think it caught a
lot of teams uh unawares and then um
by the time they kind of caught it on um
it was a bit too late and we kind of
transformed our identity really like
hurricanes always being a team of attack
and expect unexpected and yet all of a
sudden we were this um this defensive
unit that we're just swarming and
forcing teams back at every
at every stride so that's you know and
then obviously we won the final but i
think that defensive master stroke was
probably something that i'll never
forget and how we
managed to change in the middle of the
year and win it that way
and there's another moment that sort of
changed it all around too it was a
incident of the the famous five famous
five guys who went out had a big had a
big night in africa when they weren't
allowed to
[Laughter]
i don't think we lost the game after
that and um some say you give you give
yourself credit for that
oh look i'm always going to look for the
bright side of things um it was one of
those it was funny because um
where obviously we're in durban and um
we had an early dinner that night i
think was a tuesday night
early dinner and i think we were pretty
much done by six o'clock and i
i knew it was going to be my last season
and i was like what i've never done
because i love a punt like i probably
normally go to the casa and just sit
there for a few hours and friggin play
blackjack or play some play some poker
that's normally what i like to do but i
was like you know what i want to change
it up i'm just going to go and have a
drink have a quiet drink by myself and
just reminisce and then head back to the
hotel because we had a curfew obviously
and six o'clock like that's the only
doors all right anyway one quiet drink
they decided to oh mate yeah last year
we've got to make the most of this like
got to make the most of this let's this
has come together and we'll just have
one drink we'll head home i was like bro
six o'clock of course mate i can't
remember who ordered the shots
but
once the shots came in like i can't
really remember much after that
mate i think while we got home after
curfew 100 enough to curfew i got to my
room
my roomie i thought was out
but i must have been making a hell of a
noise freaking i think i must have
spewed into the bloody taller bowl or
something
[ __ ] went for a piss fell over like i
was in all sorts and anyway i woke up
the next day
i was in bed day off
next minute
my roomie comes back after having a day
out and then uh he comes back and like
we're just lying there just talking and
then i'm like
rich um did you hear me come in last
night he's like bro i thought you'd
never ask i was like
[Laughter]
well i thought i'd gotten away with it
and then uh yeah the rest is history but
um
look it was so funny because like i was
one of the names um i'd never do
anything like that like i never honestly
back in my days i'd always like be the
first guy to beard never drink and then
i just thought you know what like i've
been
been like that for so long i'm just
gonna
enjoy myself but ended up having four
other mates so
yeah it was uh and then from then on um
obviously we got dropped the boys uh we
had a game we literally won from then on
and uh that's why i like to say i just
created a little bit more tightness
between the brothers you
know
the fact that we got pumped by the
sharks 2a like that probably made it so
much more worse i reckon if we won that
game you probably wouldn't have been
dropped
oh yeah exactly exactly bro if we had
won that game but obviously sharks you
know i don't think would have we won
there yet
oh good question not sure but yeah i
don't i don't think i don't think we
have like even up till then we had a one
there and obviously we actually trained
really well that's the crazy thing we
trained well on thursday trained well on
friday and then saturday like just
literally absolutely nothing like oh man
they spanked us
and so deservedly so we got dropped and
you know i guess the rest is history and
we just won 8 on the trot i think it was
and then what was it like once that
final whistle had gone 2016 final you
obviously get your tongue going for some
reason
any story behind that one
yes bro literally it just happened in
the moment i think it happened the week
before too like i think
it was almost like i was trying to say i
told you but for some reason
i just went started bringing the tongue
out i don't know what no and i just
remembered it for the next week because
someone i think bears had me up the week
before like just before the phone is
like what was that about i was i don't
know but if i'm doing it again we'll be
happy boys
and so i just knew as soon as that
whistle went i had to do it again so
even though i mean absolutely nothing it
was just like my celebration after
scoring in wellington and the sevens
like i never celebrate so i for some
reason i just did the cross i put my
hands up and i've
not not a winger's celebration by any
sort of anything
oh good times good times at the
hurricanes but one thing we haven't even
mentioned about yet is your all black
career
so um
when did when was your debut for the all
blacks
it was in the june series in 2010
against ireland um
so that was up in new plymouth
and we played uh we played them we beat
them in all three games and i got a run
i was on the bench
against irish came on in the second half
with about 20 to go
played against ronan o'gara
yeah
so that's quite funny some of the boys
have a bit of a laugh at our time when
the coach has pictures of me playing
with them too so
but yeah no that was my debut
what was it like being named for the
first time as well that's always a
moment that everyone loves
oh mate it was um
absolute heaven on earth mate like i
absolutely dreamed of that moment
right from the get-go and then it's
funny like because like ma i hung around
with him obviously when i was one of my
boys in the canes and he'd always be
dropping hints you know like he's like
bro i reckon you'll be there and i was
like
don't like
there was i'd never talk to the coaches
there's been nothing like no comms
but like for most of these like no no i
reckon you'll be sweet but like you know
you can't think and go down their track
because otherwise you know all of a
sudden you're playing like an egg and
anyway and so when it finally happened
um you know we're all sitting at home
actually amber was there too literally
met her
two weeks before in the club
she was as she was at the house with my
family and um
we were in the back in the kitchen
because like the naming was happening in
the lounge where everyone was by the tv
and um they were all watching and all of
a sudden like
just heard this massive scream like i
didn't even watch it because i i was
just so nervous i wanted to make it so
bad and then when i heard their scream i
knew i could finally join them
and then
yeah i freaking got a call uh from
shandy and
they told me the rest uh details what's
back and all that sort of thing so
man it was um it was a bit of a blur
really and then media not long after
like it's
it's crazy man i think everyone talks
about their first selection and what
happens and it's definitely a moment you
never forget
did you feel comfortable going in there
no
not at all really um i i was really just
looking forward to finding um
finding my wellington mates like conrad
and maher and just really trying to get
alongside those guys you know because
those are the guys i know we've got
perry as well and there's all net mere
um
just oh yeah i knew i'd be comfortable
around them but even then like
you know that the all blacks you know so
much history and all that it's man i was
nervous and my first ever roommate was
was richie
and so
like they always bloody do that i
figured that out later but they always
did it and unfortunately my plan came in
before his
and so what i did was i got to the room
and i saw there were no bags and i knew
i was with him and i was like i can't
choose a bed here so i literally put my
crap
put my crap to the side like the
concierge brought it up and i went down
five an hour in the team room and i just
sat there and then richie walked in and
he was like oh mate uh concierge got
your bag ups your bags upstairs and i
was like oh yeah
upstairs
and then i'd seen that he chose the the
room uh closest to the doors oh yes we
i'll go through the other one
mate so nervous bro i'm nervous talking
about it now still like it's crazy what
your body does man i was like oh
yeah
pretty nervous but ended up
and the rugby side of things what was
the biggest difference for you going
into the all blacks from a rugby point
of view
i think the attention to detail um was
probably the biggest thing
um attention to detail and how long you
had to concentrate forward meetings and
just really
just kind of the socratic method too
with the way they worked like in terms
of asking questions to anyone you know
like i used to normally in the
hurricanes like it's kind of your
leaders they talk a lot more and every
now and then they might ask a young guy
but you know we've got games every week
so we kind of just roll into it but with
the all blacks like every test is big
everyone's got to contribute everyone's
a leader on the day so
um you know
i figured out pretty quick though that
you can't really look away too much
because that's when they'll come for you
it's more like when they're looking for
someone like you just like look like
i've asked me but really it's like don't
ask me
uh i think that was the biggest thing
was just being able to um just to learn
off the grates and have those guys
around and you just didn't want to be
the guy that asked a dumb question or
you know like put it for wrong in
training but um being a young guy that's
always going to happen at some point so
yeah it's uh it was daunting but it
definitely got easier with some of the
lads that were there
and and your debut start was that
against aussie
debut yes it was against aussie
yeah what do you remember about that
game
oh that game what a game
um i remember starting on the blind side
and i remember we had a defensive scrum
again here's my bane the defensive scrum
and then i um
i think ben mickelman he was a and he
he picked the ball but in the hurricanes
because i was fast enough a couple of
times
at flank i would go straight to the
winger
and so because i could cover it but that
was just absolutely new but i was just
like i left them completely and i went
to the winger me and izzy were in the
middle of comms and then he was like
crouch set and i was like okay i'm just
going to get to the wing because he's
the hardest guy literally i just drifted
off the eight obviously he went through
made an offload and they scored a try to
get ahead we ended up winning their game
but after that um it was obviously the
last game of the of the series and then
we had end of year announced and i
missed out on their team literally
literally because all the other games
have been good literally because of
their one tackle that i'd missed
um and so
yeah that was a pretty you know pretty
quick made in 2010 end of 2010 i hadn't
even made the end of your tour i don't
think anyone's had a quicker exit
so and that was and the hardest thing
was you know those are the tough tests
you know the during series and then
playing the spring box and the aussies
and then the fun one is the one when you
get to go to the end of year and i
didn't get to go on it so
made um learn the learnt the harshness
of the the kiwi critics pretty quickly
um and if anything that's when amber and
i obviously uh we just decided to go on
a bit of a tiki tour so we went to the
states
um and just did a massive trip through
there for about three or four weeks and
then came back just to just to have a
bit of a
an unwind
and what's it like going in and then
back out because everyone's obviously so
happy that you're an all black they're
calling you an all black and then you
you're back out of there straight away
and it what's that like to deal with
oh man it's
the first time was definitely the worst
like as they say the first cuts the
deepest and i think it was just because
of all the buildup of actually making it
and
then just knowing it was just one
literally one mistake
and we obviously won the game but you
know i hadn't earned my stripes enough
yet to
to be making those sorts of mistakes and
then you know
i and i understood because i knew how
cutthroat it was i knew how hard it was
to get there
um looking back is a little bit harsh
but um
at the same time um you know we had so
many talented guys like adam thompson
there miss him like you know you don't
it's all black ruby you don't make those
sorts of mistakes and get away with it
so
i think um and jerome obviously didn't
start their game just to just to give me
a go
and so there's you know legions that
you're keeping off if you're not going
to be adding to the legacy it's probably
time you go figure out how to do it
another time so
it's uh it's tough man you know
obviously people come around your family
like people kind of like oh like they
don't know what to say and you're kind
of like just it's all right just talk to
me i haven't died like life goes on but
um for a lot of people it kind of feels
like that so the first time was hardest
and then even the second time i got
dropped
um like that's the funny thing about
moblix journey literally
double world cup winner i was lucky
enough to be around for those times but
i literally got dropped a couple of
times and then out with injury so it's
almost like i was out of the team a few
times
but always seemed to be coming back in
uh so i've been pretty lucky for that
journey i guess that kind of helped keep
my keep my feet on the ground too to be
fair
and you spoke about the rugby world cup
leading up to that uh 2011 rugby world
captured yeah did you think you were
going to make that squad
how to the no um
so
yeah 2011 i was just playing uh my team
cup and we had our
our shoulder version like midweek games
because obviously the the competition
had to get done before the world cup
their home
and then um
played a relatively decent game one time
against canterbury at home i scored a
try and set up a couple others and then
the all blacks just happened to be in
wellington
their week
and
i managed to catch them while they were
training at rugby league and i was just
sawing some of the coaches they said
you're playing good rugby but like it
literally was just the conversation and
passing
and then i think we went away to play
bad plenty that we won that game
then they called me to come away with
them to support elizabeth for one of
their last tests before they named the
name the team and played with the team
the whole year you know missed our end
of 2010
hadn't played it all in 2011.
um
and so they asked me to come away
because they wanted to rest guys like
richie and kieran i think as well
and so they you know i think they gave a
start to like tomo uh liam uh then other
guys and then myself like
we was gonna be on the bench just to
sort of give those guys a rest and i was
like well okay that makes sense you
gotta look after these guys i've got a
freaking big world cup coming up
and then um
yeah anyway we went away to pe
um liam started he came off i went on
did nothing special but we lost their
game
um
and then they read out the team uh that
next morning i was telling amber that
morning like can't wait to come home
can't wait to see you
and then they read out the team and they
didn't read a limb and they didn't read
out a few other guys but they read out
me and um
mate i was i just didn't believe it man
it was like i couldn't believe it like
they didn't have any combos no nothing
literally they came in as a gap for like
literally best of the rest to come help
out
but um mate yeah literally happened just
like that and then they talked to me on
the way but then we had one more game
actually sorry go through brisbane we
had to go back home through brisbane to
play the aussies
um and then kieran actually got injured
in the first 10 minutes i think he did
and then
yeah i came on and i'll never forget
brad thorne was like this is now where
you make him up mate play tough
so this big thorny maze friggin legend
and then yeah it just gave me the
confidence i needed you know um and we
ended up but i think we won that game
in the end with a richer scoring try but
yeah anyway like honestly we lost their
game so we lost two on the trot
lost two on the truck heading into a
world cup but personally i had a pretty
good game
um and so it just gave me a bit more
confidence to to know that maybe i did
belong to to try to help the boys get a
world cup on home soil
ah that's crazy to hear and so what was
it like going leading into that world
cup obviously the whole weight of the
nation was on the all blacks everyone
had high expectations everyone was right
the country got right in behind that 1a
so what was that like uh playing in that
tournament
mate um i think the pool rounds were
were awesome like it's just so nice
being at home being close to all your
family
having everyone so close to be able to
visit and have midweek lunches you know
doing things you'd never be able to do
you know normal tests when you're
traveling and back and forth
but then obviously come you know
quarters and semis and finals
i think um yeah obviously the anxiety
started kicking in for the nation and
all of a sudden you couldn't be having a
coffee down in the lobby at 7 30 at
night everyone's thinking you should be
upstairs uh getting some rest and all
that kind of thing so
the pressure was definitely um getting
transferred onto the boys so we kind of
had to just hold up a little bit and
stay in our rooms and
you know um
do the right you know do the right
things in the eyes of the public because
that's probably one thing about being at
home is you know you can't be out doing
movies and stuff because everyone's got
an opinion as to what a professional
should be doing so
you know luckily um the weight of a
nation literally uh was able to
be a lead alleviated uh once we won that
fun after their final whistle against
the french but um holy heck there was a
lot of pressure so how did the 2015
world cup compare did you was it a
similar situation did you think you were
going to make it this year because like
you said i've already mentioned you were
in and out of the um squad quite a bit
um 2015 yeah that was um
yeah like i got injured with my neck in
2014
and so i've been out for quite a while
uh and i got injured in super rugby and
so i
didn't manage to get away uh to play you
know that june series with the all
blacks in fact i played one game um but
then i had to take some time out because
of my neck injury and i just thought
well i haven't played any rugby didn't
even get to play mitre 10 and then i
ended up playing
a couple of minor team games and luckily
um got the call up for the end of year
but hadn't done anything special there
was still guys a stephen law tour he had
an amazing season paddy tupalotu came in
you know and obviously the the split
with locks and lucy's all those things
come into play and
again i just got lucky 2015 i think
steven law tour was out with an injury
paddy tupelotu needed to have surgery
um and then i played a game in eden park
literally the last game before the all
blacks team got announced that i
started and i played really really well
and so i um just put my hand up again
and we ended up taking uh six lucy's uh
in the end to the world cup i you know i
think um
kind of forced my way in there so and we
only took up took three locks
so it was made again just lucky to be
around when um you know because i know
if petty tubes was available it probably
would have been just easier to take five
and three i'm well sorry um take four
locks which you normally would
so made it's just yeah just lucky again
really and how did that tournament
compare footy wise
oh i think um
yeah there was so much less pressure for
some reason like yes the pressure was
there because it won the year before but
we're away from home we knew we actually
enjoyed being in enemy territory if
anything and we um
yeah and we knew with the experience of
having 2011 that their monkey was off
the back and if anything it was just a
nice warm wind that our back to help us
experience wise a lot of these guys are
still there obviously with
richie dan ma you know all these greats
and you know that team had a bunch of
guys that just knew how to win and the
rest of us young guys obviously that are
there just helping it along but you know
those guys were pretty much able to
coach the teams the team themselves in
the last in the last couple of weeks
because of uh just all the experience
they had from 2011 and obviously between
um made it was unreal it's unreal that
uh we just didn't feel like we're going
to lose to be fair in a lot of those
games the only game was probably against
south africa
was um was where was quite tight in the
semi-final but otherwise um it just felt
it just felt almost distant really but
especially for those guys that finished
up their careers in the year
and what the celebrations like what's a
celebration like after rugby world cup
you've obviously experienced two of them
so
oh 2011 was pretty special because um
obviously our friends and family all
around and made i actually probably
can't remember much after 5
a.m i had to get dragged into the bus
for the for the parade because i heard
the chanting outside our room where
everyone was like the streets were
absolutely packed obviously
um everyone half cut out trying to get
the all blacks out of the bit so it was
freaking it was awesome and then
obviously in uh in london
we celebrated going into town um had a
wrestling night on the town
had uh had a few photos pop up with boys
by the paparazzi over there freaking
coming out but worse for we're in the
middle of london but uh mate it was it
was good times
it was good times and uh yeah just ended
up having a good flight home as well
obviously drinking the whole way so mate
it was
pretty good to
have little billy come back with us
obviously um the world cup was me
mate
two-time rugby world cup winner how good
is it
oh so lucky bro it's been awesome lucky
to have played with some awesome players
bro just there to do my part i guess
but one thing that has stood up out
about your black career that we've sort
of spoken about is your sort of
inability to cement yourself as a first
choice all black i mean you've got all
the attributes you're big fast strong
got all the skills what derrick and held
you back from you know like being a
hundred cap
all black
um it's funny you asked like
yeah it's probably one thing that steve
stevenson always said to me like
you'd always ask a question i'd say
something he's like mate just don't
overthink it like don't overthink it and
i think i've always been someone that
was a bit of an overthinker like
probably because um like i said i came
through scots i
broke this all down obviously in my
years after i've left but um after i
left when i was at scots
like we had no real game plans we didn't
have set piece stuff we didn't do any
rugby theory like there was no
literally was give a couple of us the
ball and i was one of them and we just
play like there was no and then by the
time i made like rugby
rugby squads they had proper like ids
and misses and all this other stuff and
rap moves i was like literally it was
just above me it was like algebra it was
like absolutely hieroglyphics trying to
read it for me
um and so a lot of the time i'd be
always trying to do more homework always
trying to think that i was way behind
the ball like the eight ball that i
wasn't quite really so i'd always be
overthinking things and so
if anything that was my biggest
challenge was just
just trusting myself you know just
trusting myself that i know my roles i
know what i'm doing
just go um
and part of that source i do in my
school like i said like i'm always
thinking about what if like i've always
got
preparation scenarios instead of just
freaking staying in the moment so there
was a battle that i always had and i
timed it well enough to to have a decent
resume but like you say um
i'd love to have uh been a little bit
more in the moment and just trusted
myself back in those days but there's no
regrets it's just interesting to have to
thought back to it yeah if you could go
back what how would you do that
differently
uh
i probably i don't know like i
feel like
it couldn't have happened any other way
to be honest like i just because
i became quite studious you know
studying the game and knowing trying to
know different roles and
um obviously i was on the bench as well
for the all blacks a lot and i always
had to know six seven and eight and the
roles were pretty different
um and we didn't want to shift anyone
around when they came in like we wanted
our jumpers like all the guys for them
to do their role the best i needed to
know every single role really really
well and i think
definitely played in my mind a little
bit because it was like if i was doing
ritchie's role i'll be following the
rocks a lot if i was doing longer where
i'll probably be hanging out a little
bit more but obviously a little bit more
ball carrying if i was doing rito's role
i'll be swinging in and out of the off
the team every now and then like it was
it was quite um
it was quite a lot for me to take in as
a sub but i relished that challenge too
um it probably clip like cleared me up a
little bit but i i love that part of it
too because
yeah
i would have loved to have strung more
starts together to be fair like if i was
able to get more starts i probably in
one roll that would have been awesome
but um mate you know when you get a
first start and you make a bad reader
and eight like you're not going to get
trusted very often so
hopefully uh and you've got guys like
karen and richie and jerome like i was
never ever um unaware of the fact that
you got some pretty great players um
ahead of you
um mate so interesting to hear was there
anyone who sort of helped you sort of go
through that journey of your
decluttering are you still are you still
like that you're still overthinking the
game a little bit or
what sort of helped you through this
i think if anything it's just time you
know like by the time
funnily enough by the time i left the
canes well by the time i hit 2015 by the
time i hit 2016 and left
i was in a great zone like i knew myself
i knew what i could do
i knew what i wasn't good at and what i
needed to work on but not focus on it so
much i think my blade journey
i always wanted to be they wanted me to
defend like jerry or um or loms and they
wanted me to run like this and that but
i could only ever be me you know and i
lost sight of that
and so um
yeah like getting reshaped like you
reshaped and remolded a lot of the time
i think i just lost my way a little bit
but now like as h you know what it's
like as you get older you just sort of
know yourself and made i think by the
time i got here to france
i was just ready to pop like and i had
and i had an awesome season here in
france like
it was great too they had no not too
many roles just play
and offload and see how it goes and
that's all i did and i loved it it was
awesome
so what did inspire that move to france
you were
you just won the super rugby you just
played 100 games you were still in all
black
why the move
um
i just felt like it was time for a new
challenge i mean
i think as soon as we'd won 2015 as well
um i just knew it was time to move on
um we had such a so many legends leave
the game guys that i played a lot on my
rugby with obviously as well
and so i thought maybe it's time for a
new challenge as well and i just yeah it
just seemed like the right time
and i think yeah it ended up being
perfect with the hundred games and
winning the final there couldn't have
been a better send-off really um
i think it was just great timing and
i've always been very lucky in that way
i guess
was it always lara shall i imagine
someone of your caliber would have had
plenty of different offers on the table
to decide between
there was one other there was ulster um
i could have gone to ulster
um but that was you know you know when
people would describe also to me being
like cold and freezing and weird i was
like oh oh no like
i'm definitely going to need to go
somewhere with a bit of sunshine and
then obviously la rochelle was the other
option that you know seaside town i just
thought man that's just like welling
and so um just in france so mate it was
yeah i thought it was just the the right
time to go and obviously piggy was here
he told me um made it's great people
great team and i watched some of their
highlights and there was this guy
lavaney booty i was like mate i think
these guys have got some good boise and
then honestly got here and
the lads were on a roll by the time i
got here and i was just man again timing
along for the ride and i loved every
second of it
and how did the family find the move
oh family found it tough to be fair uh
the first
first six months is definitely tough as
you know the language barrier and
there's so many um
so much paperwork over here you know
there's so much uh
so much bureaucracy to get through like
you know just to set up a bank account
or even just buy a mobile phone you've
got to like give eight different forms
of id and you're like hey no well not
that many but like it's it's crazy
honestly you gotta it's crazy over here
and it's one thing you just learn about
france and you get over it after six
months and it's only really it took us a
couple of years to be really comfortable
without being able to go find good cafes
and you know live life like it was back
home
and one thing that looks like you've
picked up really well is your french
i'll see you doing fluent interviews in
french these days so mate you're you're
a wizard
maybe you'd hope so after five nearly
six years but yeah look i think the
first year that i had here was probably
the catalyst to that you know our team
wasn't expected to do much and then all
of a sudden we're winning back-to-back
games and the boys are going out on the
town every week and
nothing uh takes out that overthinking
more than a beer you know so all of a
sudden the language was just getting
chucked out there and
just going back and forth and i was just
fully immersed in it and um yeah that
was the best way to learn luckily it was
all pre-covered obviously so
here was a good way to go
and three beautiful kids are they how
they going with their friends and
lifestyle over there
yeah got carlos who just turned seven uh
cruz who's five in talia who's two
turning three um
yeah they they had their challenges like
carlos you know he could tell that um we
weren't in new zealand anymore for when
we first got here at nearly two years
old and he took a while getting used to
the nunu and the language he's just they
would be talking to him and he's just
like
yeah just uh bust out crying i wasn't
happy one bit
um but he got used to it cruz was born
here um and so he's
just recently started liking speaking
french he's just so stubborn like
because we speak samoan at home as well
so three languages is a bit a little bit
much on the kids i guess but um they're
starting to come around and talia she's
um
she's the little girl that just runs
around just confident airs because she
knows he's got two older brothers around
here so she's she's alive man
so you're fluent in samoa and french and
obviously english
english is so bad but yeah
the french in someone yeah i think uh
yeah luckily enough three languages um
don't speak anywhere near enough so i'm
on at the moment it's only really when i
see my mum or on on facetime and that so
yeah i would love to once i get back to
get crack into that a bit more too but
i'd love to keep my fringe as well it's
been pretty pretty cool having that
can amber speak french
uh
not as well as she should not as well as
she should
to be fair to her like she's been living
at home being living the life of a
stay-at-home mom and she doesn't really
and obviously coverts like rock darwin
we can't go out as much and and
socialize so
you know she her conversations
unfortunately are just with me and a few
other foreign wives and doesn't get to
go out often and see other frenchies so
um she can she can understand a lot
though but she she just needs to back
herself a bit more just that probably
she's a bit of an overthinker like me
too i think
and we've sort of spoken about your
plans like your
your body's your body's sore but um
you're coming to the india contract have
you have you made much of a plan
do you know what's ahead for you
um
oh man it's uh it's a hard one at the
moment i mean it's all i've got a bit of
a rest now because of the bullies so
my knee feels not so bad you know so i'm
telling myself look i'm just gonna
i was gonna wait it out and see how i go
because um
you know the minds willing the minds
ready to to go again and obviously i
think la rochelle we can make a real
good goal of it this year again because
we made literally two finals last year
and missed out so i'm hoping that
their record runs like the way it was
for us in hurricanes that we can win one
this year
but um yeah i'm just looking off looking
at the knee and how that's going and
then i'll be able to make some more uh
more decisions but whether i finish up
or not i'm not sure mate it's uh i'm
ready i'm ready to finish up but also if
this knee is good
who knows might sign on for one more
so what is the plan when you finish up i
know you're someone who's put a lot of
time and effort into your life after
rugby plan and you're someone who's
obviously going to be very successful
once you do finish what is the plans
i mean if i choose to finish up i think
if anything um like you said luckily
i've got a bit of a
you know i've been able to get a couple
of properties that can provide a little
bit of income there and
half of wellington
[ __ ] no no no no no no um
it's going to be able to put food on the
table and whatnot so
we won't be pressured that much but i
know we're going to still want to put
our minds and
hearts into some something you know yeah
maybe a business or something but i
don't know i've just got to go back and
sample some stuff because i literally
don't know mate like
i've been doing this job for 17 odd
years um i think i'm just going to go
and have to try and fail a few different
things and then i'll know what i don't
like and
and just pick it up on the way like
everyone else i guess um
it's you know it's funny like you a lot
of people think you've got to have it
figured out then i talked to some guys
even like conrad a couple years ago
asked him he's like may i don't really
know i'm like mate conrad smith are you
sure
i mean he always had a law degree and
he's pretty switched on but you know
that you know it doesn't necessarily
mean he he'd wanted to be a lawyer per
se so maybe it's a it's a question
that's always tough but um you know
recently i started speaking to a
therapist actually just um we had a bit
of a service um
through the canes uh all the the cain's
old boys network
and um we used the lady from there and
she wasn't so bad but wasn't quite
aligned with uh how i wanted to do
things and then i met another another
lady who got recommended to me by a good
mate who had used her as well and if
anything it was just to sort of uh dig
into some stuff as to
find some blind spots i guess as to
where you know i'm
confident in who i think i am or who i
know i am but it's always good to you
know we talked about overthinking before
but i'm sure there's other
friggin uh things i've got about me that
i need to be aware of if i'm really
gonna be okay once uh once this game
finishes up
that's so cool so did you just think
what made you think that you needed to
go see a therapist or someone was it was
something happening or you just
genuinely just interested to find out
more about yourself
i was honestly i was just generally
interested because you know there's you
know there's quotes around like you
you're probably the easiest person to
fool you know yourself
and so i just thought man like i feel
like i'm all right but i just would love
to
hear
the perspective of someone that's
trained and able to sort of give you an
insight into some of your habits and
what you've done and who you are and why
you do certain things
um
and man it was it was worth it you know
i've only done a couple of sessions now
but um the first one is just a real
casual conversation getting to know each
other but then after that like you could
dig in and talk go through some history
and stuff that's happened to you in the
past and it wasn't anything per se but
it was just real
i could see like you know it's kind of
life is going to change and i knew that
and there's going to be challenges ahead
and i just wanted to make sure i knew a
little bit more about myself before i
took myself out of the safety then as
rugby really
no that's so cool because you often hear
when when you think about a therapist or
a counselor you often think people are
struggling or um they're going through
something tough but
you've been proactive with it with that
and you've you've got you've reached out
early and you've you've had to think
about what's
what your personality is like and i
guess
bulletproofing yourself for what's about
to happen
yeah i mean i've i'm luckily you know
i've got a i've got a good mate who um
who had used this person before and he's
in the states and over in america like
everyone's got a therapist like i think
it's just over in uh back home
in new zealand and maybe aussie but like
that it's seen as like a bottom of the
cliff sort of thing like you say i'm
just waiting for something to go wrong
in your life before you hit them up but
literally nothing's going wrong in
people's lives in america in the states
and they just go see them just to
unload and talk about what's going on
and even the good things you know they
like to share that and
um i thought you know when he told me
that i was like man well that's um
that's actually a really good way to
look at it you know so
um and i was supporting him the whole
time going man you got to do it man you
got to do it and then he was like well
what about you and i was like oh
bro i'm all good hey and it was like hey
hey hey you just told me that it's all
good and you don't want it i was like
all right you know what okay you're
right so um yeah i just ended up
putting in an email to the canes and
then obviously to this other lady and
man i loved it so it's um i'm going to
be setting up another session soon just
to just to have another check because
you know it could be done in six months
and yeah a lot of things change for me
and my family and and what that looks
like obviously it's um it's my own
perspective that's going to have to to
shift with everything
um well so cool and what what options
have you got i know you're you're a
talented actor yeah you're into politics
yeah you've got so many options you're a
good dancer
what are you thinking life after what's
up
um
well
it turns off though look honestly i'm
not even
if anything my main my main goal is to
get if i do finish up is to get home and
set up the kids
um and then just
just see where it goes from there you
know take it day by day um
i really love my my last time back home
i was home for for about a month and
caught up with a few friends and
like made it just went by so quickly and
they were all doing such awesome things
and
like running their businesses and doing
things and i mean i just being able to
be amongst that and get inspired i think
naturally i just i just want to learn
you know again and i think um that's
what is quite exciting about the other
side of footy like i haven't learned
everything in footy by any stretch of
the imagination but there's always going
to be a transition coming at some point
and i think there was one game actually
where i took a head knock and i was a
bit slow for about 10 days to two weeks
and mate i i just was like man the last
thing i want to do is freaking lose my
marbles and not be able to
to actually use my brain and do there's
a lot of living to be done after footy
you know so i think that's what kind of
prompted uh some of these uh
proactive moves i guess and
yeah i think that's uh i'll just go home
and chill get the kids right because
obviously i've got my family to think
about and then then amber and i will go
from there because you know she's been
living her life here this whole time
being a mother and i'm excited to see
what she wants to do as well you know so
that's that's all in the next step
yeah and she's a very driven and um
intelligent person as well isn't she so
i'm sure she's got some pretty big goals
that she wants to achieve as well yeah
she's got some good little ideas and man
i'm like pretty quick to try and steal
them i'm like yeah yeah i reckon we
should do this this and then she's like
whoa whoa whoa this is my idea so i'm
like all right all right but um
surely i'll be helping you a little bit
she's like yeah yeah but get your own
i'm like
[Laughter]
oh looking forward to that no doubt
whatever you choose you too will be very
very successful anyway as always we've
gone to our instagram for some questions
and victor vito
someone all black legend has got so many
questions coming and a lot of them
actually were about what we've already
talked about was the samoan switch would
you be
keen to make that um change which you
obviously already have spoken about but
first question
um who is your favorite young player
currently
who's my favorite young player currently
um
i quite like caleb clark
um he's
i just love watching the way he runs a
bit like his old man and his messives
though he's going so fast but he's in
the way he just backs himself i think um
yeah i always loved that you know he
came into the environment
and then pretty soon after he was
ripping it up and i always loved
seeing young guys rip it up like that uh
straight off the bat so yeah caleb club
he's a little bit like you if you chose
on that chose to play wang
shut up
hell of a lot more explosive than me bro
he freaking doesn't go down for anyone
that guy
okay next one do you still have your
michael jackson cd
um
mate i love you some mj um not in cd but
i've definitely got a lot of mj on my on
my spotify playlist now
are you a big michael fan
dancing singing
mate love lil mj it's uh he has a bit of
a legendary i mean bloody oh he's uh
yeah he's everything for me when i was
young and yeah i always wanted to go to
one of his concerts but uh unfortunately
i wasn't old enough to go so
yeah it is what it is
okay next one uh i'd love to know what
he thinks of ronan ogara as a coach
oh ronan made um no rona's a good coach
he's
he's pretty approachable you know he's
pretty good in that way and that he's
actually quite open to having a yak
about how you might want to see the team
rolling as a player and then working it
into the game plans in there but then
also he's got a good his big big picture
thinker you know like he gets the boys
motivated loves his videos as well
he loves the hype up video we literally
do one every week so
it's uh we're always quite excited it
gets the boys going trying to see what's
what's coming up next then um mate it's
it's very good for the environment so
now run has been pretty good
oh it's good to hear okay next one uh
what did it mean for you to become a
summer and chief
yeah that was um
there was a a big milestone for me
personally it was more because my um
well at the time my granddad he wasn't
in the best health and he had his uh his
chief told her that he wanted to bestow
upon some of the young some of the boys
so there were four of us actually
uh the sons of his eldest his four
eldest and um
yeah it meant a lot now obviously now i
can um i can vote in some way politics
and whatnot i haven't been able to do
that obviously not being over there but
um yeah it just gives me a little bit
more standing as all just to help out
with my family and i think that's
something that's always been there
another reason why i always
sort of thought ahead is to say how i'm
going to be looking after my family and
loved ones once this game's finished
with me
so what is the role of achieve
well at the moment to be honest it's
just every now and then you might have
to give some money to the village if
there's a falafel like a death or a um
it literally means bother in sanborn
like a bother
so it's a wedding or a funeral basically
any time they've you got to come
together and put some money in
and it doesn't happen very often my
grandma normally gives me a yell if um
if i need to help out and if there's
some decisions pertaining to the family
um we have a little bit of a say but if
anything grandma and my mums and all
that get the say anyway that but we get
to speak at least but they don't listen
every time
have you been back to samoa since you've
become a chief
i went back we had a reunion in 2018.
and uh yeah just literally was just a
quick hello to the village where i
retrieved um and then it was just to the
reunion from there and yeah amber and i
talk quite often about how
how centering it was to go back and the
kids loved it because you're just so
free like everything's so cheap and
your life is pretty pretty relaxed over
there but obviously um not many
entrepreneurial things able to really
launch over there
online mate
yeah
so yeah we love that back there and
we've even talked about having a place
there one day so
we'll see
hey so many options okay next one
victor vito would be the captain of my
all time skux15 who else would he have
in his side
captain oh [ __ ]
um
fifteen skutz guys oh man i don't know i
think i
i'm not gonna give you i'll just go
sonny bill obviously he's uh everyone
loves that guy
um
yeah i know there's too many skulls guys
jimmy my you got to be up there mate
nelson's finest
thanks
at least i mean
the
[Laughter]
what's the secret to being so shredded
oh you'll be able to tell us jimmy
intermittent fasting mate
do you still do it
oh nowhere near as much as i should man
like
yeah i
honestly have just been
yeah
it's i think because we have breakfast
provided for us here by the club and
when i first got here literally i still
it's a bit of fasting didn't eat in the
mornings until like two or three in the
afternoon
yeah and then um yeah like you actually
got fined if you didn't come to
breakfast
and so
well the boys find you just it's just
the thing the frenchies they love a
little uh they love pranks they love
doing fines you'd love it here bro you'd
absolutely love it here
um and so yeah so i just got over
sitting down and just drinking coffee
you know i started eating and since then
i've just
do it like literally when i start seeing
a little bit of hanu going around the
gut i just like oh yeah i probably need
to tighten the ship up for a couple of
weeks
but i've been there so yeah intermittent
fasting i definitely swear by it
so did you do that throughout your
hurricanes in all black career
yeah i did that pretty much every day
throughout my whole career um would
avoid breakfast uh sometimes if i felt
like it was going to be a big day i
would have a little bit but generally i
would be intimidating fasting most of
the time
and there's all sorts of kill the gene
videos of you on youtube was that what
was that was that what was it what was
that
there was um
we were just trying to release a book
and we thought we'd do it on
intermittent fasting by killing the gene
killing the fat gene we caught it just a
bit of a marketing ploy there
um
and just because i was a bit subby
obviously and even in high school and
then literally um did sevens inhibited
fasting and
yeah managed to
get a decent rig i guess and then yeah
he decided to make a book around it we
did some videos but it was crack up like
me working out pointing at the camera
like pouring water on my oh mate it's so
encouraged to think back to you now but
yeah i love a little bit of acting done
i love it acting you know that freaking
doing your videos for for hammers uh for
hammer when you were the way
one of the groups
oh would you would you seriously get
into acting i remember like shortland
street was always a semi goal for you at
some point would you would you like to
do that
i'll talk it down now but secretly i'll
be
very very happy if i was able to do an
acting career after this um mate i would
love to give it a go i'd love to give it
a go
why not once the kids are settled we'll
see what happens and i might have to fly
up to hollywood now
because you're good mates with the rock
too aren't you and people compare them
to you
no [ __ ] no no
i'm uh this is one of my best mates is
his cousin so i was able to give him a
jersey one time but literally that's
no i'm not good mates with the rock
don't go that much of me you're good
though you're good
would you message him to for an acting
career even if it was like uh um you
know the who are the guys just because
when they brought in the
play to breakfast i was like
yeah
no would not have the balls to message
him at all but um acting would be pretty
cool like i'm already acting already
like freaking
playing rugby you don't go around town
trying to tackle people in town so
just different role
playing a different character
who would play you in a movie
uh
i have this argument with tarwood all
the time because he says we are like
these bad boys obviously there's will
smith and martin lawrence and he says
i'm martin lawrence but i'll have to say
wolf smith i would love will smith to
play me
who played you in the um the kick the
beaver movie
do you know i think there was a guy
bringing in the waters that never made
the screen
that would probably be me bro
i would i did not think i was even there
[Laughter]
should have caught me would have been
king
yeah play yourself okay last one last
question
best piece of advice victor vito has for
our listeners
just whatever it is you're going to do
back yourself
uh no point uh half-assing it i think um
definitely learned that obviously
throughout my career and obviously
through the show event um
if you're going to do something just
back yourself and no reservations
oh i knew it it was a classic victor
vito i just can't see it
mate i could see you just hit a zone and
you went for it oh
poetry in motion
you've got a gift that's something you
could definitely follow
advice mentoring
something like that
yeah something like that
anyway mate obviously
unreal yarn really appreciate you giving
up your time and coming on the podcast
uh it's been awesome following your
journey obviously our wives are best
friends and mate i was lucky enough to
live with you guys for a for a year
there and see how it all rolled and you
took me under your wing and mate been
awesome following your journey since
then and i'm seeing you progress through
the all blacks win the double world cups
and become a french legend it's been
pretty special to watch and what i'm
most looking forward to seeing is what
you do after ag because i know whatever
you do do you're gonna you're gonna kill
it so i'm really looking forward to
seeing that and really appreciate you
coming on the podcast and giving up your
time mate
no thanks jim um you know it's i'm
always pretty pretty nervous with these
sorts of things with podcasts i don't
really do them but um made up i was
always going to be able to i was always
going to be happy to try and do them
with what a lad it's awesome seeing how
well you're doing and giving your
platform to the lads to to share some of
your thoughts on that so man i really
appreciate you as well and really
appreciate you uh wanting to wanting to
have a chat
you're one of the greats appreciate it
brother
[Music]
absolutely
[Music]
[Music]